IRFAN: Hello.
Good afternoon, everybody.
And welcome to KitchenSync.
My name is Irfan.
I'm the chef at Baadal, which
is the Indian restaurant
across campus.
So I'd like everyone
to welcome Josey Baker.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSEY BAKER: Thank
you very much.
That's very flattering.
Thank you for having
me and everybody
who's welcomed me here.
I feel very, very comfy.
So that's really nice.
And yeah, it was funny.
I was driving down.
So I'm Josey Baker.
My businesses Josey
Baker Bread, and I'm
a co-owner of The Mill, which is
a cafe bakery in San Francisco
that I co-own with
Four Barrel Coffee.
And that's where we
bake all of our bread.
But I got my start a little over
five years ago baking at home.
And I just had a buddy
who was traveling
through San Francisco who had
a sourdough starter with him.
And I said, "Why do you
have sourdough starter?"
You can't-- I didn't really
think you could bake good bread
at home.
He said, yeah, you
can bake good bread.
So he scribbled down
some instructions
and gifted me a little
bit of sourdough starter.
And a few days later I tried
it and just completely fell
in love with the
process of baking bread.
And the nice thing about
the process of baking bread
is, the product is bread.
And bread is really nice
to share with people.
But I loved baking
so much that I just
started doing it all the time.
And again, you're
left with bread
after you go through
the process of baking.
Originally, I just started
storing the extra loaves
in my freezer.
And then my roommate
said, man, you
can't store more
bread in the freezer.
I said, OK.
I'm eating as much as I can.
I start giving it away.
And then one day a friend
says, I'll give you some money,
because he was getting
a lot bread from me.
You know, I'll give
you a few bucks.
And I said, [SNAP] oh!
Sell the bread.
Good idea, Michael.
And that was sort
of how it began.
And funny enough, I didn't
even do this on purpose.
But this tub that
this dough is in
was one of the first
pieces of baking equipment
that I purchased.
And at the time I was
like, this is so huge.
This could hold so much dough.
And now at the mill, you know,
we're doing 350 loaves a day
or so.
But I drove down in
my truck with it.
And it felt like the good
old days because what I did
is I started baking at
home, and then started
selling it originally just
to friends and neighbors,
and then to strangers,
and pretty quickly had
to find a bigger space
to make the bread.
So I started renting space
from other businesses,
from MissionPie, which is a
pie bakery in the Mission,
then Pizzaiolo, which is an
Italian restaurant, California
Italian restaurant in Oakland
with a wood fired oven.
And I was doing
that all by myself.
And then Jeremy Tooker,
who's the founder, owner
of Four Barrel Coffee approached
me and asked me if I wanted
to do a project with him.
And so we opened The Mill.
So that's me in a nutshell.
So what I'm going to talk about
today is, I'm really excited.
I've been fermenting some
ideas for a different type
of presentation.
I've done lots of how to make
bread at home classes before.
And I'm going to do that today.
But I'm going to have
kind of a new overlay
to it, which I think
are the principles that
make good bread.
And so if you take
these principles,
you can really apply
them to any style
of bread-- well, any grain,
really, which, at The Mill,
we have a stone
mill in our bakery.
And we're always doing
lots of experimentation
with different types of grain.
And I sort of stepped back and
looked at all of our breads
and sort of uncovered these
principles that were really
at the heart of all of
our breads, which are,
they're sort of provocative.
Actually, wait.
Before I get that.
So what makes good bread?
This is just my opinion.
But obviously, it
tastes good, right?
And so the types of bread
that I'm most interested in
are pretty simple breads.
They're breads that evoke the
most flavor from the grain
itself that the
bread is made from.
Not to say-- I love me
a delicious sweet bread
that's filled with
butter and sugar
and all types of, you know,
raisins and cheeses and all
those things.
It makes a delicious bread.
But what's most interesting to
me from the baking perspective
is really trying to evoke all of
the flavor from a grain itself.
So it tastes good.
It's good for you, right?
Bread is-- it can be,
I think it should be,
the cornerstone of a healthy
diet-- which, not all bread can
fill that role.
And a loaf of bread
should keep well.
Yeah?
You should be able to have it
for a few days, ideally, not
because of a bunch of
artificial preservatives
that are pumped into it.
And made from responsible,
sustainable ingredients.
Yeah?
We all want to be good to
this world we're a part of.
And so, how do we get
all of those things?
I think one way is to follow
these five principles, which
are whole, wild,
wet, slow, and bold.
Right?
And so what do
those things mean?
So that's what I'm going to
go through while showing you
how to make a loaf of bread.
So there are handouts here.
Just do me a favor.
Don't get too caught up in them
throughout this presentation.
I'm not going to
really follow that.
That stands on its own.
You can follow that at home.
It has exact quantities of all
the ingredients and everything.
Mostly what I want to
try to get out of this
is just some
helpful tidbits that
will inspire you to
actually give it a shot
because it's really
not that hard.
So whole.
Whole grain.
Let's see.
So at The Mill, we
have-- and lots of people
don't actually realize this.
But we have a mill, which is
the namesake of the place.
And so it's a stone mill.
And we use that mill to freshly
mill all of our whole grain
flour.
And my mind is constantly being
blown by the variety of grains
that you can use
for bread making.
And so today, I just brought
two different whole grain stone
ground flours.
This is Sonora flour,
which is a variety that
has a really rich history
here in California.
It's grown about two hours
northeast of the bakery.
I'll pass it around.
It's really light in
color, mild in flavor.
Just pass it around.
And so that is a
type of white wheat.
And here in this
big bag, which is
what I'm going to use to mix
up a little bit of dough,
is some red wheat.
And so there's many
different types of wheat.
Red wheat and white wheat
are just categories.
You've probably heard of spelt,
of camut, emmer, of durum,
of rye.
Rye is not wheat.
But it is a grain
from which you can
make totally delicious bread,
which is one of the breads
that you'll all be eating today.
The other bread
that you'll try is
the bread made from
that Sonora, which
we call California Heirloom.
So most bread is made
from white flour.
And what I mean by
that is, white flour
is what you get if you
take powdered wheat berries
and you take out the wheat
bran and the wheat germ.
OK?
And so when you take
those things out,
you have a pretty
shelf stable product.
And you have a product
that's not as good for you
and doesn't actually
taste as good.
Definitely doesn't
taste as strongly.
There aren't as many
flavors that are in there.
I prefer bread that's made
with mostly whole grain.
Again, I'm not
knocking white flour.
We use a bunch of
it at the bakery.
You can make really sweet,
airy loaves of bread.
I just think if we're
trying to make bread that
is really nutritive and
could be the cornerstone
of a healthy diet, you need a
lot of whole grains in there.
So the recipe that
ya'll have there
is for 100% whole wheat bread.
There's also a
few notes in there
that if you want to add some
bread flour, lighten it up,
you can totally do that.
No problem.
Do I want to accept
questions as we go?
Or should I just blast?
IRFAN: Well we can.
But I think best would be to
go through and then accept
questions right at the end
so that the presentation goes
smooth.
JOSEY BAKER: Great.
Don't derail me with
any hard questions.
IRFAN: Don't worry.
You got it.
JOSEY BAKER: OK.
So that's whole, in a nutshell.
Next up, wild.
What I mean by wild is
wild yeast, sourdough.
So we make all sourdough
bread at The Mill.
We don't make, necessarily,
sour tasting bread.
Sourdough is just a
culture of wild yeast
and bacteria in flour and water.
And it's wild.
It's the ambient yeasts that
are present on the grain,
in the bakery, in the
air, in your aura.
And you use that to
make your bread rise,
to give it amazing flavors,
to help it keep well.
Totally delicious
breads can be made
from commercial yeast, yeast
that's made in a factory
that you can buy in a store.
You can only use a little bit
because if you use too much,
it ferments too quickly.
Great flavors don't develop.
The bread's going to
stale really quickly.
We use all sourdough.
It makes bread that's
more digestible.
And it adds a layer of
complexity to the process.
But I think it's
really worth it.
And in the bakery
what we actually do--
and this may
confuse some of you,
but it also may really
simplify it for some of you--
is we actually, for
most of our breads,
we don't even have a separate
sourdough starter that we use.
We actually just use some dough.
So on today, we're
mixing our dough.
My bakers are back in the
bakery right now mixing dough.
And they're going to take
a bunch of that dough.
And they're just going to put
it in the fridge until tomorrow.
And then they'll mix that
into that day's bread dough.
And it's all the same thing.
It's all flour and water,
salt, wild yeast, bacteria.
Yeah.
So, obviously you can't
do that-- well, my guess
is you can't do that at home
because you're probably not
baking bread every day.
So it's a little bit
more practical to have
a sourdough starter that
you maintain on its own.
And so, when you're starting
the life of a loaf of bread--
and to feed your
starter, so simple.
So, so, so simple.
You throw out most of it.
You compost it.
And trust me.
You want to compost it because
if you don't compost it--
because what I used
to do was I was like,
I can't compost the starter.
I can't throw it out.
It's my little pet.
That pains me.
And so I would
just bake with it.
And then you end
up in my position.
OK?
So don't.
So you just take a
little bit of it.
Let's see, here.
Yeah, don't worry about
the exact quantity.
Oh yeah.
Move this?
Yeah.
Also, some folks,
I think, are really
intimidated by using a scale.
If you are interested
in bread baking,
getting a scale is going to so
drastically simplify your life,
especially in the early
phases, because you don't
have that judgment to
know, oh, the dough's
a little bit too wet.
Oh, the dough's a
little bit too dry.
And if you're measuring
by volume, a cup of flour,
there's a huge range in how much
flour actually fits in a cup.
And so, because you're not
able to say, oh, shoot.
I should add a
little bit more water
because I compacted
the flour in the cup.
It just kind of slows
your learning process,
whereas if you use a scale,
you know exactly how much
of everything you've added.
And it's a breeze.
So I, honestly, I didn't even
use a scale for the first six,
eight months I was baking.
Obviously, you can do it.
There's plenty of great
recipes out there.
But I think it's really helpful.
So we'll put in a little
bit of sourdough starter.
IRFAN: Now Josey, where can
we buy sourdough starter?
JOSEY BAKER: So you can actually
make your own sourdough starter
yourself.
It's super simple.
You just mix together
flour and water
and you let it sit for a day.
You throw out most of it.
You do it again.
And if you use whole
grain rye flour,
you're going to have a better
chance of having success
with that.
And you basically just do
that for two weeks or so.
And you should have
a healthy starter.
You can visit a bakery, see if
they'll part with some of it.
I'm going to pour in
a little bit of water.
A little more.
I'm just winging it here.
Don't pay attention
to the quantities.
I'm just showing you
the basic process.
You want to break
up the starter.
And so, another
thing that I think
is really intimidating
when you're first
learning how to bake is how to
fit it into your life, right?
You're all at work right now.
You can't be like, doing
this hours long process.
But it's actually really easy
to fit it into your life.
And the way to do that
is to use the fridge.
And you basically can do any
of these phases of the process,
stick the dough in the fridge,
and then just get to it
when you're home from
work or when you woke up
or when you're back
from your camping trip.
It's really actually
very flexible.
OK.
And now, a little bit of
this whole grain flour.
Could I get just a
spoon, a wooden spoon?
Thank you.
Yeah.
And all I'm going
to show you here
is about what the
consistency should look like.
Yeah.
That's my hope, is to give you
just some sort of landmarks,
some signposts along the
way, so you can say, oh yeah.
This kind of looks
like what he did.
This is just one way of
making bread, though.
There's many different ways.
Again, so you see how I'm
relying on my judgment here.
If you have a scale, you
just pour in-- oh god,
I keep doing that--
if you have a scale,
you just pour in
the exact amount.
And you don't worry about it.
OK?
So something like that.
Can you see this?
Yeah.
It's kind of like a
thick pancake batter.
Yeah?
And at about this consistency,
with about that much starter,
this is going to be
good to go for-- you
let it sit for eight to 12
hours at room temperature.
Yeah?
So that's a nice number, right?
It's about how long
you're at work,
somewhere in there, about
how long you're sleeping.
And you'll come back to it.
And it will have all sorts
of bubbles on the surface.
It'll look like
it's really alive.
And that's great.
That's what you want.
You're sort of getting this--
this is like a pre-dough.
Yeah?
You're getting this ready to
mix into your bread dough.
But it's just the same thing.
It's a little bit of
starter, flour, water.
And so we're just going
to do that again, right?
So we're going to fast
forward eight to 12 hours.
This is smelling nice.
You can see bubbles.
Yeah?
And so that brings me to the
third principle, which is wet.
Wet dough.
Yeah?
So most bread dough, it's just
not made with enough water.
Right?
And it's made not
with enough water
because it's really easy to
handle stiff bread dough,
right?
So if any of you have
made bread or you've
seen people make bread
before, they mix the dough.
And then, if they're
doing it by hand,
they put it out on the counter.
And they use some flour.
And they rub it
around and push it.
And we're not going to
actually do any of that.
We're going to leave it in
the bowl the whole time.
And we're just
going to use water
to have it not stick to things.
I think that, especially with
whole grain flours, whole grain
breads, it just
needs more water.
You've got that bran
and germ in there.
It's going to soak
up more water.
That's going to lead to a better
texture in your bread, better
flavors in your bread, and
better keeping quality, right?
Starts out with more
water, it's going
to retain more water over time.
Some people say high hydration,
high hydration doughs.
I've started saying fully
hydrated doughs or properly
hydrated doughs, because
high hydration kind of misses
the point depending on what
grain you're working with,
because some
grains-- every grain
has a different absorption.
Yeah?
And so like that sonora,
that light colored flour
in the bread that
we're going to eat?
That particular crop
is super absorbent.
It absorbs 30% more
water than another grain
that we work with.
But we also make this bread.
It's probably my favorite
bread that I, unfortunately,
don't have today because
the grain ran out.
Einkorn bread.
That bread absorbs-- the Einkorn
absorbs 75 grams of water
for every 100 grams of flour.
That Sonora absorbs
110 grams of water
for every 100 grams of flour.
So a huge difference, right?
So calling the Einkorn
high hydration-- it's
a little misleading.
Anyway.
So we're going to put water in.
And we're just going to disperse
your sourdough pre-ferment
here.
Just get it dissolved in there.
And when you're
doing this at home,
you're paying really close
attention to the numbers here.
Yeah?
Right?
You're going to add some
more whole wheat flour.
And this really, this is
exactly the same process
we do at the bakery, just
obviously in a much smaller
scale.
But this is it.
The thing that makes
it tricky is that--
and you'll learn this, which
is what makes bread baking
infinitely challenging and
fulfilling and intriguing,
is that every day--
especially if you're
working with a sourdough
culture-- every day,
things are a little
bit different.
And so you have to really
be tuned into the dough.
So this would be a
really wet dough.
I'm going to add
a little bit more.
And again, when
you're starting out,
it's OK to add a little
bit more flour just
to make things easier
to handle, because it
can be kind of a
bummer if you're
going through the process of
making your loaf of bread,
you're all excited, you got your
friends coming over for dinner
the next night-- I'm baking
bread for the party--
and you get to the shaping
phase of bread baking.
And you screw it all up,
which I've done many times.
IRFAN: So you're using water
to shape rather than flour?
JOSEY BAKER: Yes.
Well, I'm going to use
flour to do the final shape
in a little bit.
But yeah.
I'm just trying to
not-- I'm trying
to keep the ratio of flour
and water in that sweet spot.
And if anything, I go a
little bit on the wet side.
IRFAN: OK.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
IRFAN: So while
you're working, is it
OK to ask you a
couple questions?
JOSEY BAKER: Of course, man.
IRFAN: OK.
So for the bunch of us who
shop at regular grocery stores,
what kind of flour do
you recommend we get?
JOSEY BAKER: We are very
fortunate to have some really
nice options that are
local, like Giusto's.
Central Milling is a
company up in Petaluma.
I don't think their
flour is super easy
to find in grocery stores.
But I, for the first year or so,
I would go to Rainbow Grocery
in San Francisco and just like,
load up my backpack with like,
you know, I'd stand in the bulk
bin filling up sacks of flour,
which I think they use Giusto's.
King Arthur Flour is something
that's really widely available.
It's a great flour
company out of Vermont.
IRFAN: All right.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
IRFAN: Super.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah, Bob's
Red Mill is awesome.
OK.
Here's this.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys
sell flour at The Mill?
JOSEY BAKER: We also
sell flour at The Mill.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Can you
use the same flour as the bread
you're going to make?
JOSEY BAKER: No.
AUDIENCE: Can you
[? repeat that? ?]
JOSEY BAKER: He's
wondering about,
with your starter, what kind
of flour do you have to use.
Do you have to use the same?
And no, you don't.
So even this starter
that I brought,
because we don't use a starter
for most of our breads--
we don't use a
starter that we keep
separate from most of our breads
we do that old dough method.
But this is actually
a rye starter,
because we do keep a
starter for our rye bread
because we don't make
it every single day.
But so this was all
whole grain rye flour.
And then I just added
whole wheat flour.
Just something to
consider is that, whatever
flour you use for your
starter, that flour's
going to then be in your
final loaf of bread, right?
So if you don't mind a little
bit of rye, no problem.
Yeah.
I forgot one thing in this.
Who can tell me what it is?
AUDIENCE: Salt.
JOSEY BAKER: Salt. It
is a rite of passage.
It's a rite of passage
in the life of a baker
to forget the salt, which at
home, you're very disappointed
in yourself when it happens.
In a bakery where we're
making 350 loaves,
you've got a few people that
are very disappointed in you.
But really, you
usually can find a way
to make it work because
basically, what you then
have is a starter.
But you're going to
be mixing it again
because if you
don't have the salt,
the dough's ferment
a lot faster.
Salt actually
slows fermentation.
It also helps bring out
the flavors of the grain.
But you'll know it
before you bake it off
because the dough will
be behaving differently
than usual.
AUDIENCE: Are you using
sugar for fermentation?
JOSEY BAKER: Say
that one more time.
AUDIENCE: Are you using
a sugar for fermentation?
JOSEY BAKER: No.
No.
AUDIENCE: So it
works without sugar?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
Totally.
Yeah, just--
AUDIENCE: Some people think
that you need the sugar to--
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
So there's lots of opinions out
there on sourdough starters.
Some people use pineapple juice.
Some people use raisins.
I've had great experience using
whole grain rye flour and water
and nothing else.
That's not to say that,
in certain environments
with certain flours,
that might not be enough.
I just haven't experienced it.
Nor have I experienced
it from anybody
I've directly talked with.
So I'm just going to
fold that salt in.
Just going to mush it in.
AUDIENCE: Can you
overmix at any point?
IRFAN: The question is, can
you overmix at any point?
JOSEY BAKER: If you're
mixing it in a machine
mixer-- who asked that?
If you're mixing it in a
machine mixer you totally can.
By hand, you don't really
have to worry about it.
Yeah.
And this method that I
describe in the handout
and I'm showing you
now, just all hand mix.
You're just getting
the salt incorporated.
IRFAN: Still is pretty sticky.
JOSEY BAKER: Yes it is.
This would be on
the stickier side.
If you're feeling like being
wild, that would be fine.
Probably would be a little
bit tricky to deal with
if you haven't
handled much dough.
OK.
Whole, wild, wet.
AUDIENCE: Slow.
JOSEY BAKER: Slow.
[INAUDIBLE] Slow.
So what I mean by that--
slow fermentation, right?
Most bread is made in a few
hours from the time the flour
and water, salt, yeast
are mixed together,
to the point when its baked.
You can pull it off on
a timescale like that.
But bread's really going to be
better if you don't rush it,
right?
And that's one of the things
that I loved about baking
from the very
beginning, was that it
made me slow down and just--
when the dough is fermenting,
you can't do anything but wait.
And it's kind of
nice to be engaged
in a practice that requires
you to engage in that waiting.
The way we do things at
The Mill is, today we're
mixing up bread dough
with our starter, which
is just yesterday's dough.
And this afternoon, we'll
shape it into bread loves.
And then we'll
put in the fridge.
And we'll bake it
tomorrow morning.
So again, that fridge.
If I could give you
one little trick.
It's like, bread baking
can really easily
fit into your life.
Just use the fridge.
I used to stick bread
dough in the fridge
all weekend long while I'd
go out on a camping trip.
And I'd come back.
And I'd bake it off.
Sometimes it was disgusting.
And other times, it was
a lot better, right?
And so that's where
the subtlety comes in.
How active was your starter?
How long did you let it
sit before you shaped it
into a bread loaf?
How long did it sit
shaped in a bread loaf
before you baked it off?
Too much to get into.
But if you start
baking some bread
you'll pick up on those things.
So you do what I
just did to that.
So we're not going to
take it out and knead it
on a flour-covered
counter at all.
We're going to
stretch it and fold it
in the bowl about every
half hour for a few hours.
Yeah?
Do that about four times.
So you pull it.
Fold it back on itself.
This is exactly what
we do in the bakery.
We just do it with big bus
tubs, like 15 kilos of dough.
Yeah?
And so you're doing this.
And you can tell already.
See how the dough can
stretch a little bit, right?
It's not just like
a lump of paste.
We're developing the gluten.
And we're developing the
gluten without oxidizing
the dough, which
is what can happen
if you mix it aggressively
in a machine mixer.
And that's not going to help
you out with your flavors,
with your aromas,
with your nutrition.
And just a little bit of water.
Yeah?
And that's good.
Leave it alone for a half hour.
I go for a walk.
I read a book, take a nap.
And after a few hours of that,
again, if you want to go to bed
or you want to go to
work, just do that
and stick it in the fridge.
Just cover it up.
And just get to it
when you get to it.
AUDIENCE: Is
temperature important?
JOSEY BAKER: Temperature
is extremely important.
I, again, when I
was starting out,
I didn't take temperature of
anything for the first six,
eight months.
It leads to
unpredictable results
because that dough is a
certain temperature, right?
I just don't know what it is.
If you know what is, then
you can control things.
Yeah?
You can say, like
in the bakery, we
want this dough to be ready
to divide in three hours.
We adjust the water
temperature to an exact degree
in order to ensure that
that fermentation proceeds
at the schedule we want.
Basically the rule of thumb
is warmer temperatures
make things happen faster.
OK?
Cooler temperatures
slow things down.
I'm going to divide this dough.
So this is some dough that
was mixed up this morning.
Can I work over here?
Is this OK?
Yeah?
Slow fermentation.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering,
why do you take
that half hour break in the--
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
So in order to fully develop
the gluten with this method,
you need to let the
dough relax, right?
Because if you do
it, you'll feel it.
If you do it too much, you'll
just start tearing the dough.
Yeah?
So you slow down.
And you let some
fermentation occur,
which also helps
strengthen the gluten.
IRFAN: It's sticky.
JOSEY BAKER: Yes.
So this is a little sticky.
And I sort of cut
some corners on this.
We'll see if we
can make it work.
So again, I'm just using
a little bit of water
so that it doesn't stick.
And so now I'm going to
pre-shape the dough, which
is just making it into a round.
Just do that.
No.
When I was first
learning how to do this,
I actually used to do it
in the air, in my hands.
And that's because I
was doing it at home
and I didn't have enough
bench space on my kitchen
counter to do it.
There's lots of ways to do this.
We do it this way so that we
don't incorporate more flour,
because at this point--
so this dough has just
completed its bulk fermentation,
its first fermentation.
So all that flour has
been mixed with water.
And it's fermented.
If we incorporate
more flour now,
it's not going to have the
opportunity to ferment.
OK?
This can be tricky if you
haven't done this much before.
But it's, I think, a
little less important
than the final shape,
which I'm going to show you
how to do right afterwards.
And we're about to run out
of time, which is perfect.
Yeah?
OK?
So there's that.
And now we're going to introduce
just a little bit of flour.
And we usually do
this with bread flour.
But you can totally do it
with whole grain flour.
Where's that sonora?
This it?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
JOSEY BAKER: Does anyone?
IRFAN: Sonora.
Cool.
Here we go.
JOSEY BAKER: Great.
OK.
So I'll just do one of these.
And then I'll talk
you through the bake
real quickly, which is
the last principle, bold.
OK.
So we've put flour on top.
And you can tell
it's not sticking.
We've got a little flour
on the surface here.
So I'm going to
flip it on its head.
So we're going to just--
watch what I do here.
We're going to fold the
bottom up 2/3, 3/4 or so.
And we're going to do the
same thing to the other side.
Yeah?
Then we're going to spin it.
Nice little package, right?
So a little bit
tapered on the top.
Take this top.
Fold it down.
Then just fold it over again.
Then I'll change
this so you can see.
So here's the seam, here.
So you're just going to
use the palm of your hand.
Seam it up.
And then we're going to
put this in rice flour.
The rice flour just helps
it not stick to the basket.
You can also totally
just put this in a pan.
Then you don't need to
deal with the rice flour.
Yeah?
And then you let that sit.
You can stick it in
your fridge and just
get to it when you get to it.
Or you can let it sit out
for three, four hours,
and then bake it.
And for the bake, what you want
to do is preheat your oven.
450.
If you're baking a loaf like
this, a free form hearth loaf,
you want to have a
baking stone in there.
Then this is-- I just can't
help but show you this part.
You're going go
preheat that baking
stone for 20, 30 minutes.
And then you're going
to take your loaf
and sprinkle the
top with some flour.
Or you can use some
parchment paper as well.
And now we're jumping ahead
in the process, right?
You will have had to have
waited a few hours or overnight
or after a day at work.
And you're going to flip it out.
It'll look prettier than this.
And then you take
your razor, or lame--
this is a double-sided
razor, very thin, very sharp.
And you're going to
slash this sucker.
All right?
And this is very
exciting, when you--
it's still very exciting
for me, still doing it,
after all these years.
But it'll be very
exciting for you.
And it's a very subtle art.
But it encourages
you to really, really
tune in to this bread dough.
And voila.
[APPLAUSE]
And so you bake for 20
minutes with a metal pot.
So you take this, slide it
onto the hot baking stone,
put a metal pot on
top, wait 20 minutes,
take the metal pot
off, and at that point,
the loaf will totally
have transformed.
It will have
increased in volume.
Probably won't
have changed color
very much because it's been
baking in a steam saturated
environment.
But then when you
take that top off
and you let it finish its
bake in a dry environment,
that's where all that
delicious carmelization
is going to occur.
And I favor, encourage,
prefer a bold bake.
It's that fifth principle there.
Lots of people, if they
haven't had our bread before,
they say, well you know, like,
I heard this place was great.
And they burned all the bread.
But no.
We do it on purpose because
we think it tastes the best.
It creates the most
delicious variation
in texture between
the moist interior
and a crunchy exterior.
And yeah, pushing it
up to just shy of burnt
is really what I prefer.
And I think that
about covers it.
IRFAN: Cool.
That's fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
Are you open to
taking questions now?
JOSEY BAKER: Of course.
Yeah.
IRFAN: Does anybody have
questions in the group?
We have a microphone.
AUDIENCE: For the
metal pot technique
you suggested, do you
preheat the pot before?
IRFAN: The question is,
for the metal pot cooking,
do you preheat the pot.
JOSEY BAKER: You don't have to.
I've done it both ways.
And if you have a thin-walled
metal pot-- really,
mostly what the metal pot is
doing is trapping the steam.
Another way, which is
also totally awesome,
is to do a Dutch
oven or a Le Creuset.
And that makes the heat
blast it from all directions.
And it traps the steam.
That can be a little bit-- the
transfer of your unbaked loaf
into the Le Creuset or the
Dutch oven can be really tricky.
And I've screwed up
many a loaf doing that.
Whereas the baking
stone, it's flat.
So you just slide it on, take
that room temperature metal
pot, put it on top,
and you're good to go.
IRFAN: Cool.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
If you're doing the method using
the sourdough, just the dough,
at what point in the
process would that
be the dough that you use?
And how would it differ in
the new bread making process?
JOSEY BAKER: It kind of depends.
It depends on the activity level
of your dough, the temperature
of your fridge, all that stuff.
What we do is, we
take our dough,
our whole wheat
dough, immediately
after we're done mixing it.
And so it actually has
salt in it as well.
And we then have to divide
it up into smaller bits
so that it can
cool down quickly,
because if we took
30 kilos of dough
and put it into the
fridge, it would
take a long time to cool down.
So we break it up
into little bits
and put it right
into the fridge,
and then use it 20 hours later.
So-- say it again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSEY BAKER: No.
No.
Yeah.
And you can do that.
It's really, you
know, every once
in a while if we screw up and
like, accidentally throw away
our starter or our old
dough, you could actually
just take unbaked bread loaves.
Like, you could
take any of these
and use these as a
starter because it's
all the same thing.
It's flour, water, that
wild yeast and bacteria.
The art of it is
catching your dough
at the right phase in its
development after that fact,
right?
And I mean, obviously
that affects--
like the development
of this dough
is, it's pretty young to be used
as a starter for another dough,
which is why we stick
it in the fridge
and let it sit
there for a while.
AUDIENCE: She's got a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was reading Michael
Pollan's "Cooked."
And in the bread section,
from what I understand,
the whole milling
industry is really
built around white flour.
And wheat flour that
we buy in the store
is really just white
flour with the germ
and the bran added
back in afterwards.
So where can we home cooks
get true wheat flour?
JOSEY BAKER: You can
get it at The Mill.
You can get it at The Mill.
You can get it from-- you
know, it's a good question.
I don't know of exactly
which large mills reliably
produce whole grain flour that
hasn't been separated and then
reconstituted.
It's a very common practice.
Another surefire
way, which is pretty
impractical for most bakers,
but it's to mill your own flour.
Yeah, I can't actually
give an answer
that I'm totally positive
about on that front.
Yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I had two questions.
One was, when you
let your bread sit,
or when you let your dough sit
a little bit-- like in the past,
when I've let that happen, it
kind of gets a bit of a skin
or like a kind of
dry skin on it.
Is that just because
I haven't incorporated
enough water in my dough?
Or would that happen with
your technique or your recipes
as well?
JOSEY BAKER: At which
phase in the process?
AUDIENCE: Like, at
the end of proofing.
JOSEY BAKER: When you've
shaped it into a loaf?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah,
so that happens
because the moisture
in the dough
is evaporating off of
the surface, right,
and you're forming
a little skin.
It's usually not a big deal.
That happens sometimes in
the bakery, a little skin.
A little skin on
the, when you've
got your loaf in your basket,
a little skin on this side
can actually be really helpful
because it makes the transfer
into the oven a lot easier.
But one thing you
could do-- you know,
this depends on the
air flow in your fridge
or wherever your
dough is sitting--
but you can cover it up.
You can put this inside
of a plastic bag.
Tie the end.
You could put it inside
of a container like this.
I noticed really big
differences in the fridge
that I had based on where I
put it in the fridge, right?
Some areas are going to have a
lot more airflow than others.
So you want it in a sort of
calm, draft-free environment.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And is the
steam pot, or the pot
with the steaming
technique thing,
is that enough to
give it a good crust?
Because I know some
recipes will say, like,
spritz your oven with water
to create a steam oven first.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
So I've done a lot
of home oven baking.
And the oven that
I was baking in
at home when I started
selling my bread
was not a fancy oven at all.
It was in a little apartment
in the Mission, gas fired oven.
And for a long time, because I
was baking 12 loaves at once,
I couldn't bake them all on
baking stones with pots on top.
I would do-- I'd
throw boiling water
in the bottom of the oven, which
helps create a steam saturated
environment.
The problem is that your oven
is designed to let steam escape.
So unless you trap it in there,
it's not going to be as good.
So doing the oven within
an oven, whether that's
with the Dutch oven, the Le
Creuset or a baking stone
and a pot on top,
you can make bread
that's as good as any
professional bakery.
You really can.
The only difference is that
the professional bakery
can make hundreds,
thousands of loaves, right?
But if you have
to make one loaf,
your home oven is
totally capable.
AUDIENCE: What are your views
on the gluten free movement?
JOSEY BAKER: Good question.
Well, I think it's
great that people
are exploring different things
to help them feel better
about themselves.
And I think for
some people, eating
less of particular types of
food makes them feel better.
And that's awesome,
whatever it is.
I think what we're seeing
now with gluten and bread
and wheat is actually
really amazing
because it's raising the
awareness about how bread
is made, how wheat is grown.
And I think what practically
everybody who actually explores
that question is
going to find, is
that it's actually not gluten.
It's not wheat.
It's not bread.
It's certain types
of those things.
Yeah?
So I don't think the
question is, can I eat bread.
It's, what type of
bread can I eat.
If you want to eat bread.
If you don't want to eat
bread, then by all means,
don't eat it.
Also, some people
have celiac disease.
And they have a very
serious reaction to gluten.
And I'm not questioning
that at all.
But there is-- it's
a fad right now.
And I've been really encouraged
by every single person who's
written me an email or come
into The Mill and said, hey,
I haven't eaten
bread in a while.
But I hear that you have some
bread that actually doesn't
bother people who
are allergic or who
are sensitive to wheat
or to grain or to bread.
And they eat our bread.
And it doesn't
bother them at all.
And why is that?
Because the way that we
make bread and the way
that I just taught
you how to make bread
is totally different than the
way that most bread is made,
which is made on a
really large scale
in a really short amount
of time with ingredients
that are mass produced.
And nutrition is not
really on the radar, right?
Or it's kind of an after fact.
And it's sort of pumped
into it in weird forms.
Yeah.
So, does that?
We make a gluten free
bread, though, at The Mill.
And for people who do have
a really serious sensitivity
to gluten and to wheat, they
love that we offer that.
And I'm really
proud to offer that.
Yes sir?
AUDIENCE: Could you
comment on the trade
off in the texture and
flavor of the ultimate bread
between the folding and kneading
every half hour that you
demonstrated and a no-knead
method where you're
relying strictly upon
time and fermentation
to develop the texture?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
So no-knead, for those
of you who don't know,
is a totally awesome technique
that was popularized.
It was an article in
the New York Times
with Mark Bittman and Jim Lahey
from Sullivan Street Bakery.
He's a really talented guy.
And you can make an incredible
loaf of bread in your home oven
with very little work.
You don't need it at all.
You just mix together the
flour, water, salt, little bit
of yeast.
You let it sit for a long time.
Sort of flop it
into a round shape,
let it sit for a little
bit, bake it off.
I've tried that method
with more whole grain
flours and haven't had
quite as much luck with it.
I think that it's an
amazing method if you
use primarily white flour.
So if you're going
to use that method,
I think you'll
have the best luck
if you use mostly white flour.
I'm open to hearing
other experiences.
That just hasn't
been my experience.
But that's also not
a sourdough bread.
Yeah?
And so with the
sourdough fermentation,
you have to expel a little bit--
put a little bit more energy
into the bread dough in
order to develop that gluten
and have the type of
fermentation that's
going to lead to a
delicious loaf of bread,
rather than just leaving
it alone completely.
IRFAN: Thank you.
We have time for
one more question.
And I believe the
microphone is right there.
JOSEY BAKER: Hi.
I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
from an entrepreneurial
standpoint what
your journey was
like from, you know,
I had this idea to bake
bread and sell it, to,
I now have a mill and a bakery.
And I sell bread.
And also, what do
you do with the bread
that you don't sell
at the end of the day?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
Yeah, it's been a
pretty quick journey.
And now, you know, I
think most of my energy
is really spent on sort
of big picture stuff
and the relationships that
exist, both within my business
and with my businesses
and other businesses
and our customers and stuff.
So I spend a lot
of time thinking
about those relationships,
which was a surprise to me.
You know, I had no
idea that I would
spend as much time on my
computer and in conversation
with people when I decided
I was going to be a baker.
But it's been, I think it was a
bit of a-- worked to my benefit
how little I knew, because I
just kind of made things up
as I went.
And I didn't totally know how
difficult it was going to be.
And I said yes to things
over and over again.
And you know, I still sort of
am surprised when I look back
on the last few years and
how much my day to day life
has changed and how
the business has grown.
But yeah.
I'm really fortunate
to be able to say
that I work with
an amazing group
of passionate, talented people.
And they make the best bread
that we know how to make.
So, does that kind of
answer your question?
IRFAN: Cool.
All right.
Thank you.
This was an amazing class.
JOSEY BAKER: Thank you.
IRFAN: And it was really
great learning from you.
So Josey Baker, everybody.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]